safe passage  up captain Avery what the [ __ ] that  we're done okay  yeah now get to that [ __ ] okay to me  your ads in this place a place oh  [ __ ] hell ah [ __ ] looks like Howard  didn't make it I'll have to repair that  I condensers myself nice [ __ ] ok what is  that oh these are little [ __ ] nuts it  gotta do  all right now let's stay close by or  that far there's next we'll hear this  okay guys had a [ __ ] breath gonna get  that like a limitless wrong part so I  should have done in a great beavercreek  lanes fascinating there it is and a lot  that's second what the [ __ ] cool not so  much you here to see now shut ya all  right captain a right yeah Jess  marriott betch those fog condensers her  back online good our water supply was  starting to get low wasn't sure how much  longer we could hold did you guys that  he's my earlier food I should never have  let him go well I said it armani [ __ ]  oh yeah I can't argue I matter dicks out  for her Amish